[Music]
on this Friday night firsthand accounts
from heartbroken Hawaiians I've never
seen something ravaged so fast one
family's frantic jump into the ocean to
Escape The Inferno
okay Daddy arnita Garcia reports from
Maui
Canada's Wildfire forecast firefighting
is ultimately a Band-Aid solution the
predictions and the federal government's
goal to protect communities
volatile situation a chemical plant in
Toronto erupts in flames and how times
have changed it's 4 30. 4 30. we'll eat
dinner at 4 30. why more people are
having supper earlier
global national with baronessor
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us the developments are only
getting more Grim after destructive
wildfires wiped out an historic Hawaiian
town at least 67 people have now died
due to the Lahaina Blaze and that's just
from one fire there are multiple fires
burning across the island of Maui which
sadly means there will be more deaths
recorded this was the view from a
passenger plane showing just how much of
Maui has been engulfed in flames within
that charred landscape the devastated
community of Lahaina now the site of an
unprecedented catastrophe
we are seeing loss of life
here as you know the number has been
rising and we will continue to see loss
of life what we saw was likely the
largest natural disaster in Hawaii State
history
it's estimated about 1 000 people are
still missing and there are also
thousands of others who have been
displaced while tourists can go home
most residents have no home to return to
people lost everything homes
jobs
your cars some their pets
there's still people missing
I fought wildfires in California
and I've never and I was here yesterday
when it flared up and I've never seen
something ravaged so fast
Anita Garcia is on the island of Maui
tonight and has been speaking with
evacuees neither what's it like on the
ground there
pharah I'm in the Kihei area of Maui and
like much of the island winds have been
strong and consistent here many are
hoping Mother Nature will continue to
help firefighters get the upper hand as
they try to understand the scope of what
happened here
my husband and I are doing okay you know
it is
spiritually difficult Lisa Pua is living
in limbo now staying with her daughter
on the other side of Maui after she
rushed out of Lahaina her home there is
still standing but most of the historic
town around it has been reduced to
Rubble there weren't tiles flying off of
our roof it really is heartbreaking
communication networks are crippled and
resources are running low pua'a got
access inside Lahaina Thursday where she
says people are unable to get word out
and some are still stranded since
there's no communication no way to tell
people where the
services are we saw a crowd of people on
a corner with all of these gas cans
waiting you know trying to get gas so
they can at least get their cars and
come to this side where all the
resources are also stranded our families
at the airport camped out on concrete
floors waiting for a flight out we could
see the Flames we could see the smoke
billowing and there was a lot of panic
Jacqueline mayuga situation is unique I
won a free trip to Maui from A Wheel of
Fortune episode
so I well not exactly a year ago I'd
like to solve sure feeling a papaya yeah
that's it
mayuga says Community Support is helping
everyone get through an anxious time
everyone's watching out for people's
stuff when they use the restrooms to
take sink showers so that's been really
nice everyone's being really respectful
of how we're all sleeping on the floor
sharing blankets staff at Hawaii
airports are doing what they can to lift
Spirits travel out of the state is busy
but flights in are limited this Thursday
night flight from Honolulu to Maui
virtually empty as countries including
Canada warn against non-essential travel
to Maui up in lahainaluna I know people
line on Luna Road they couldn't get out
service you know it was really really
spotty we couldn't reach out and let
everybody know we're okay right away as
residents like pua'a hope for
communication networks and other key
lifelines to be restored
that lack of power and cell service
could have contributed to failed alerts
meant to warn residents and tourists of
the incoming Wildfire many of the
buildings have yet to be searched and as
many as 1 000 people remain missing or
unaccounted for it has some of the
residents we've heard from here
wondering why more warning wasn't
provided or if anything more could have
been done to save lives pharah
Hawaii Hawaii good questions thank you
for that
countless families have been forever
changed by this tragedy but one Survivor
story stands out it's unimaginable a
California father who was on vacation in
Maui with his wife and five kids were
headed to dinner in Lahaina an outing
that turned into a fight for survival
we got really real when we saw the
flaves
um I had to think faster we had to get
out we left our vehicle
and my my myself now I even our five
kids we all got in the ocean uh we found
a floating board that we hung out to
everything was burning around explosions
cars blowing up Amber still flying just
this we couldn't breathe the little
areas it's the carbon monoxide and we
held on as best as we could by my wife
my kids but all those help with the
young ones
for three hours waves kept pulling the
family of seven deeper into the ocean
final fight
um this is survival Rodriguez Russia
uses and they had to calm down I worked
in the ER in 15 years you got to help my
kids are amazing they they were really
good my little girl it's like you knew
that are you okay Daddy will be okay
locals who had also jumped in the ocean
helped get them to the sea wall That's
where firefighters eventually found them
battered and bruised but alive thoughts
and bruises there my wife the Emirates
Shredder High a little bit you got
checked out it was just it's scarred but
you know I think we don't see all those
very were pushing us so hard since all
my kids have bruises it cut our nose
Spades they really stopped Tire
exhausted there's the ocean so all of a
sudden my kids away a few times left but
yeah
we stuck together we held on a little
Elite I wouldn't We're not gonna buy
this way the emotional toll and Trauma
is deep and it'll take time to unpack
thankfully and Incredibly that family's
physical scars are minor in comparison
now Lahaina was once the capital of the
Hawaiian Kingdom the destruction this
week has wiped away or damaged many of
the town's historic sites and that
includes one of its most beloved symbols
located at the center of Lahaina and
towering at more than 18 meters the
town's 150 year old Banyan Tree was
charred by the fires it's uncertain
whether it will fully recover yet the
tree the largest of its kind in the U.S
remains standing I get from India
planted in 1873 decades before Hawaii
became a U.S territory it's witness
history and provided shade for community
events for Generations it's been called
the heartbeat of Lahaina
what happened in Maui Could Happen
anywhere and it's a fear so many
Canadians feel as we live through this
country's worst Wildfire season our
dangerous reality has changed in recent
years because fires aren't just burning
in the back country they're increasingly
burning close to residential areas and
they're burning from coast to coast to
coast putting a strain on resources and
on firefighters as Mackenzie gray
explains the forecast for the rest of
the fire season is dire and the impact
on our environment is extensive
the worst Wildfire season in Canadian
history has no end in sight this year's
already devastating season is not yet
over particularly for those of us who
live here in British Columbia
from BC to Ontario severely increased
Wildfire risk is expected to continue
through September contributing to the
13.4 million hectares of land burned
across the country that's more than Nova
Scotia and New Brunswick both entirely
Going Up in Smoke and nearly twice the
previous worst year on record a total
that will increase across the country
there are uh 1138 wildfires burning with
817 fires designated as out of control
to fight the record fires the federal
government announced a four hundred
thousand dollar partnership to train
firefighters this training will
certainly keep our community
firefighters safer and enhance their
skills nearly 6 000 Canadian
firefighters have been deployed across
the country but International Help has
also been needed
12 different countries including the U.S
South Africa and Brazil have all sent
personnel with 965 still fighting the
Flames firefighting is ultimately a
Band-Aid solution yes we need it but the
cost of preventing climate change is
much smaller than letting it run rampant
and then trying to to clean up the mess
climate change and Wildfire is now part
of a vicious cycle the intensity and
frequency of the fires exacerbated by
climate change and the carbon dioxide
released into the atmosphere from the
Flames increasing global warming Natural
Resources Canada projecting 1 billion
tons of carbon dioxide has been released
this Wildfire season that's 33 percent
more than the entire emissions released
in all of Canada last year and is the
equivalent to an additional 1 billion
cars on the road when wildfires are
burning through forests they're
consuming vegetation that's actually
releasing carbon into the atmosphere the
record wildfires have already had a
major economic impact with 160 000
Canadians forced to evacuate their homes
a number Farah that will likely rise in
the coming weeks
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie
to Toronto now where firefighters have
been working around the clock battling a
massive Blaze Flames broke out overnight
lighting up the sky and sending thick
black smoke billowing from an industrial
site Brittany Rosen joins us from this
scene Brittany what do we know about the
materials that are burning
hi pharah well when we first arrived
here on scene this morning it smelled
like an absolute campfire but it seems
Crews now have the upper hand they have
contained this fire it was all coming
from that chemical plant just a few
hundred meters away from where I'm
standing the City's Fire Department says
that this company housed a large amount
of chemicals including motor oil and
fluids
the six alarm fire broke out at a West
Toronto chemical facility early Friday
morning thick black Billows of smoke
filled the air as more than 100
firefighters battled towering Flames
Andrew Turk owns a maintenance business
nearby did you see anything uh just on
video surveillance overnight big
Fireball like you know when we just went
through the video and a new Freeze Frame
at the time it's like boom it's like a
huge huge Fireball yeah massive this is
the image he's referring to a fireball
lighting up the sky
and as the sun came up Crews doused the
building with water from all directions
officials say no injuries were reported
but things could have been a lot worse
what was burning was motor oil there are
different parts of the buildings where
there are some solvents which would have
been far more problematic for US
brentane Canada the company that owns
the facility is a distributor of 10 00
industrial and Specialty Chemicals
according to its website while parts of
the facility were salvaged the damage is
substantial I will say it's certainly
millions of dollars what is usually a
bustling Industrial Area was a ghost
town as police closed nearby roads and
forced staff out of the area fine with
Turk who is grateful his business was
untouched we got a whole building full
of hundred thousand square foot wheel of
toilet paper so yeah if you've let a
match there it's not it's not going to
last very long officials say there was
no concern when it comes to the air
quality they also add they don't believe
the fire was set intentionally the
province's fire marshal has been called
in to investigate the cause further
Farah Brittany Rosen in Toronto thank
you Brittany
a cloud of uncertainty hangs over Niger
coming up what cool leaders are facing
and the concerns for the ousted
president
[Music]
a heart-stopping scene in southern
Ukraine yesterday close to where
children were playing after finishing a
day camp Russian missiles targeted and
hit a hotel in the heart of zaparisia it
was frequently used by United Nations
staff Aid workers and journalists
that's Ukrainian president velodimir
zielinski announcing he's cracked down
on corruption within his country
following a meeting of Ukraine's
National Security Council zielinski
fired the head of Ukraine's military
recruitment centers zielinski says
review revealed signs of abuses from
illegal enrichment to transporting men
eligible to be drafted across the border
now to the deepening political crisis in
Niger West African leaders attending an
emergency Summit ordered a stand by
force to prepare for possible military
intervention they maintain their top
priority or after last month's coup is
the peaceful return to power of
Nigeria's democratically elected
president what is Crystal gemancing
Reports there are growing fears for
Muhammad bazoom's well-being
beeping horns and throngs of people
outside of a French military base in
niger's capital it's another
demonstration in Miami against the west
and in support of the military coup
there's going to have to be some real
negotiations some real carrots and
sticks I think Chris Roberts has been
studying African politics for 30 years
he says the West African block approving
armed intervention to restore niger's
Constitution doesn't mean an escalation
will take place
no option
is taken off the table
including the use of force
as a last resort
the protection of democracy is within
the economic community of West African
States mandate but the step towards
military intervention could be a
pressure tactic Muhammad bazoom has not
conceded power despite being taken
hostage by the military on July 26th his
party says he and his family are being
held in cruel and inhumane conditions
fears echoed by the UN and the U.S we
have
deep concern for him for his family for
his security and well-being
those who depose bazoom say they did it
because people are suffering and
National Security has not improved it's
unclear if their goal is to hand over
power to a new civilian leader or like
what transpired in neighboring Burkina
Faso and Mali delay that transition and
keep the country under military rule
stopping that Trend could explain why
the West African group moved to approve
military intervention we could call it a
a small escalatory step while echoa
still focuses on Peaceful means to
resolve this crisis meanwhile no
timeline has been given for the
activation of the African bloc's
military units Crystal gomancing Global
News London
I had the two high profile cases
involving a former U.S president and the
son of the current president
in Washington the U.S attorney general
named a special counsel to investigate
the president's son Hunter Biden
Republicans claim Hunter Biden has
received preferential treatment from
prosecutors in a tax case and over
accusations of wrongdoing in his foreign
business dealings
and today a judge issued a blunt warning
to former U.S president Donald Trump's
legal team that all necessary measures
to safeguard the legal proceedings will
be taken prosecutors were seeking a
protective order to prevent Trump from
publicly sharing evidence in the
election interference case our Jackson
cross goes outside the courthouse with
more
Jackson
for our judge Tanya chukkin made it
clear that even though Donald Trump is
running a presidential campaign politics
will have no influence over her
decisions regarding the case today's
hearing was over a dispute about what
Trump and his defense team can reveal
about the government's evidence of
Trump's efforts to overturn the 2020
election prosecutors wanted a blanket
protection order the judge rejected that
but did Implement some significant
limits for example Trump can review
materials but his lawyers have to make
sure that he doesn't take any
information with him or make copies and
he can't have any electronic devices in
the room prosecutors pointed out that
Trump has shown a tendency to hang on to
materials that he simply shouldn't have
11.6 million pages of evidence and a
hard drive will soon be turned over to
Trump's legal team prosecutors have
argued that any public disclosure of
that evidence could have a chilling
effect on Witnesses especially after
Trump's recent social media Post in
which he stated if you go after me I'm
coming after you the judge warned that
all of Trump's behavior and statements
are covered by conditions of his release
that were set out last week the other
major dispute here is over the timing of
a trial prosecutors have proposed a
January 2nd 2024 start date just as the
presidential primaries get underway
Trump has said there should be no trial
until after the November election a
decision on trial timing will be made
later this month the judge warned that
any statements that could be seen as
tainting the jury pool will only add to
the urgency for a speedy trial pharah
Jackson prosco in Washington thank you
Jackson
thank you
early bird diners what's behind a new
trend at restaurants next
[Music]
it's Friday night usually a tough night
for dinner reservations right well
apparently not post pandemic Tuesday is
the new Friday and 5 PM is the new 8pm
Mike Derulo explains the change in our
habits
want to know a sure sign you're in North
America the patios are full and the
sun's still out and no matter how many
times we go to Europe
we can't seem to figure it out they eat
later than we do dinner starts at nine
so imagine how Europeans feel about
coming to Canada now because restaurants
for the most part are seeing fewer
evening reservations it used to mean
booking dinner after seven o'clock meant
you had kids or Worse you're uncool
but I never bought into that how many
hot dogs we need some say our appetite
for eating earlier is a leftover from
the pandemic when most office workers
were stuck at home no commute no need to
wait it's a hangover that's still
lingering to be sure with hybrid work
schedules in the service industry has
had to adapt to in Toronto at least the
busiest days downtown are now midweek
Mondays and Fridays people are not at
the office
um Thursdays they're taking off because
early because they're not going to work
on Friday
um and you know nowhere is really busy
in those days and I've we've never kind
of seen anything like it part of it
could be cultural evening gents how
about a nice warm lager when we're
thinking about dinner the Brits for
example are raising a glass to tradition
oh dinner ah see I call that tea where I
come from so that would be about five or
six I think for me here in Canada we
have patio time but even that's now
blending with dinner for most Canadians
to make a reservation later than seven
it better be a special occasion when do
I eat dinner
used to be five when the kids were
little and then it's like seven on
holidays let's say seven or eight and
now it's five again because I like to
eat early now we wouldn't be Canadian if
we didn't see this Oddity as a
gastronomical opportunity I was just
gonna say a place that you couldn't get
into to save your life and you have to
go early and your friends would say damn
I'll eat at six o'clock what no you can
go at eight o'clock now my friends
that's great so get there live life on
the edge and try booking a fancy dinner
a little later this weekend microlight
Global News Toronto so
good tip that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is the
fishing community of Halls Harbor in
Nova Scotia Jeff sempo will be at the
anchor desk this weekend until Monday
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
[Music]
thank you